each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
good afternoon everyone and welcome my
name is Kim rickets and I managed with
Kirsten Wiley the Microsoft Research
visiting speaker series and today we
welcome David Evans here to discuss his
work on software platforms and to tell
the stories of the most successful
software engines of our times and how
these invisible engines are driven by
economic factors and not necessarily
technological ones how many cutting-edge
ideas have dropped off the face of the
earth after failing to capture an
audience and make money he will discuss
what separates success from failure in
some applications and argue that it is
determined by a Duncan mix of pricing
and product design decisions and a keen
knowledge of the economics as well David
is the founder of market platform
dynamics and a visiting professor at
University College London his company
works with leadership teams in different
companies to design products and develop
pricing strategies to bring innovation
platforms to the market so please
welcome David him thanks very much for
having me today in the next few minutes
I'm going to begin by not talking about
anything having to do with with software
platforms but instead I want to start
out with with a few sort of commonplace
puzzles and one of the puzzles I like to
start out with before the we started
today we're talking a little bit about
shopping malls near nearby and we I
asked about some of the close ones and
someone mentioned pacific place and how
annoying it was that when you go to
pacific place in order to go from top to
bottom you have to walk across i guess
the mall in order to go down the
escalator and up the escalator and
that's actually a very common and know
anything about about shopping malls all
around the country for two level malls
the escalators tend to be an opposite in
the end of the mall so here's here's
another puzzle I have and I brought I
brought props today here's a his an
issue of vogue which is in a magazine
that I read very much but you know one
of the puzzles about vogue is if you
want to find the table of contents in
vogue so you have to pay you have to
turn to page 24 to find the first page
of the of the of the
contents if you have to thumb through to
find the first page and then you know
the other thing that's really kind of
annoying is to find the continuation of
the page of the table of contents you
have to flip forward and let's see so
then you go to page 30 define the
continuation of it and then you flip
forward a little bit farther and the
continuation is on on page 36 which is
kind of an annoying feature of this
particular of this particular magazine
and you have the same problem when you
when you want to read stories in boat
magazine and this is true for other
magazines as well it's really hard to
find the continuation so that's another
another odd fact of life that I like to
talk about a little bit and then the
final one that I want to spend a little
bit of time on is credit cards I mean
we're all very annoyed when we go home
and open up our mailboxes and they just
stuck with credit card solicitations
most of them offering us all sorts of
rewards as some of those are kind of
puzzled at that because I at least don't
don't revolve my credit card balance
that doesn't seem like a very smart
thing to do so I don't revolve yet I get
all these credit card offers and all
these fantastic reward programs and so
forth so one of the things I like to do
in the next 40 minutes is to show you
how the new economics of multiply cited
platforms helps answer some of those
puzzles and also as it turns out provide
some insights into software platforms
your core your core business so in the
next few minutes I'd actually like to
continue on by not talking at all about
software platforms but continuing with
the businesses that I've that I've just
introduced so let's take shopping malls
as an example and just to motivate this
that's a picture not of pacific place
but of a very of the largest shopping
mall in America which is the mall of
america in minneapolis so let me tell
you a little bit about shopping malls
these have been around in some form for
a century if not more depending upon how
you how you define them but the modern
shopping mall in America
was created by a fellow by the name of
Victor gruen who set up the first mall
in South bail the southdale mall outside
of Minneapolis and this particular mall
is really the the model for all shopping
malls in the United States it's a
promotion shopping malls in the United
States it's a it's a two-level mall it
has anchor stores significant stores
like a nordstroms or a Neiman Marcus and
opposite ends and then lots of stores in
the middle and then there's a courtyard
courtyard in between that's the basic
design of the American shopping mall has
become just incredibly incredibly
popular what's the business model of a
shopping mall well the business model is
shoppers by and large most malls get in
for free sometimes they may have to pay
for parking but often times even parking
is free indeed and a lot of shopping
malls at Christmastime you get free food
and entertainment and so forth so
shoppers typically don't pay anything to
get into a shopping mall at least they
don't pay anything to the shopping mall
owner and developer merchants on the
other hand do pet merchants pay rent and
a lot of shopping mall operations they
also pay some commission on the store
sales and that's the business model of
the of the shopping mall and of course
as we probably all realize after
reflecting on it for about a nanosecond
the reason the escalators are a top
attends opposite ends of the mall is
because the shopping mall owner wants to
encourage traffic he wants the shoppers
to circulate around the different stores
because that's what the merchants want
they want the foot traffic and that's
also going to generate sales for him so
that's the shopping mall model so let me
turn to advertising supported media of
which vogue is vogue is an example so
there's a picture so we have different
issues different issues of Vogue here so
if you go back to the 19th century
magazines in the United States actually
did not have advertising in them the
typical model for a magazine in America
or in most countries in the 19th century
what
is people paid for the magazine and
their articles in it and it was a very
simple business model the owner of the
magazine basically paid for content
those are his suppliers or employees as
the case may be put it between the
covers and sold the magazine for a fee
then in the late 19th century a couple
of publishers facing financial problems
came up with the idea of putting
advertising in the magazine no this
wasn't the invention of advertising
supported media because that actually
goes back a long ways with newspapers
but at least for magazines in the United
States late 19th century about eighteen
ninety five or so Muncie magazine and
another magazine introduced advertising
in their magazines and over the next ten
or twenty years the magazine industry in
the United States flipped from being
basically an advertising advertising
supported industry where by and large
readers didn't pay that much in fact the
typical model for magazines is once you
take into account production costs and
so forth readers get a really good deal
on the other hand the advertisers just
as with google and msn and advertising
supported media the money basically
comes from the from the advertising side
now just as with the shopping malls the
explanation for why you have to work so
hard to find the table of contents and
articles in a magazine like like vogue
is just as the shopping mall wants to
get consumers shoppers to walk around
the different storefronts likewise a
magazine like bhaag wants to get readers
to go through the advertisement and you
think of about the process of finding
the table of contents you have to go
through a lot of ads just to find it and
to find the continuation even more and
if you want to look at the continuation
of articles again you basically forced
to walk by in effect the advertisements
and that's a very conscious decision on
the part of the magazine now one of the
interesting things about magazines and
this is true for some of the other
business models that we're going to talk
about is they're not all the same so for
example
People magazine is actually a little bit
different than vogue so if I look at
people magazine and if I'm interested in
finding out the story about Britney
files for divorce it's real easy i just
opened the magazine i go to okay so
there's an advertisement for for
citicorp on the on the on the first and
second page but then easy to find table
of contents starting on page three I go
to page four there's the continuation of
the table of contents and the other neat
thing about People magazine is this is
also true for the Economist is um
there's a page number down it down on
the right hand corner of every page so
it's very easy to find out where you are
in the in the magazine whereas with
vogue not only is the table of contents
separated at ten you go to page 36 but
there are no page numbers to actually
make it easy for you to for you to do
that now these are examples of magazines
that have followed somewhat different
business models this is what I would
call a advertiser friendly platform
basically this magazine doesn't charge
subscribers much you can you can get
this magazine from amazon for eighteen
dollars a year whereas this is a 118
dollars a year question here I know some
people who really like to buy vogue for
the odds yep that's what they want yep
no and that's a different for other
magazines I don't know if anyone does
that brother there's a name well I think
it's it's true for some magazines not
true for other magazines and this is one
of the big debates in advertising
supported media which is due do
consumers like the ads or not and people
talk about consumers not liking the ads
on TV that there's there's a dispute
about that but I take your point that
invoke a lot of the people who buy bow
view the advertisements as part of the
content of the magazine and I and I take
that point absolutely so that's that's a
that's a very good point the observation
i want to make though is that people
magazine is a it really is a much more
of a reader-friendly magazine in terms
of the advertisements on the other hand
at the more expensive magazine whereas
this magazine is a much more advertiser
friendly magazine
accepting your point that a lot of the
consumers do like the advertisements
this is very inexpensive from the
consumer standpoint but very centered on
this is an advertising advertising
medium again there are two groups of
consumers here for both people and vogue
and potentially two sources of revenue
and two sources of profit which are
consumers and advertisers of course let
me turn now to the payment cards which
is another interesting example of of the
kind of business that I want to focus on
so let me give you a little bit a little
bit of background on the history of
payment cards up until nineteen fifty in
the United States and also throughout
the world payment cards were basically
provided by stores so you could go to
stores and you could buy on installment
you could have monthly charges and the
store would give you a card that you
could present as identification that
basically allows you to do that diners
club came in nineteen fifty Manhattan
with basically a new business model with
what I would call the general-purpose
charge card or general-purpose payment
card and the business model here is you
have a single card network you get
merchants to sign up and you get card
holders to sign up and they can use that
network as basically a mechanism for for
the consumer to pay the pay the merchant
now this was introduced in manhattan in
nineteen fifty by followed by the name
of Frank mcnamara and his business model
for getting the system off the ground
was to essentially give the card away to
consumers he literally gave it away at
the start of the system and charge
merchants basically restaurants in
Manhattan seven percent of the meal tab
now that business model where merchants
basically pay the freight for the cart
system and consumers get a really good
deal has really continued for the last
50 years if you look at payment card
systems in the United States and most
parts of the world they're essentially
consumer or card for card holder
friendly systems in which the merchant
ends up
most of the freight now in the case of
diners club eventually McNamara diners
club started charging people an annual
fee for the card but that fee
essentially just covered the cost of the
float that consumers were getting as a
result of only having to pay their card
the card balances every 30 days every 30
days or so if you look at modern payment
cards and think about the ones that you
use debit card you're really not paying
anything for the transactions or for the
card although that gets complicated
because it's bundled in with the bank
account if you take a look at credit
cards for those of us who don't result
revolve or balances which is about half
of the people who use credit cards at
least in terms of the dollar balances
you're not really paying much of
anything for a card either you get
rewards you have an annual fee but the
annual fee more or less covers covers
the float so by and large for the vast
amount of transactions that are
conducted on payment cards around the
world it's essentially the merchant pays
the way the merchant pages and modern
card systems is the the system has
something known as they have to change
fee that get passed on to the to the
merchant and that flows as income to the
bank that issues that issues the cards
so getting back to why you have all
these card solicitations in your mailbox
and why you get all these lavish reward
programs basically the competition among
banks is the sign up card holders in
order to basically deliver those two
merchants so that interchange fee income
is competed away and there are some
analogies here to what Google for
example does today in terms of rebating
some of the advertising revenue that it
gets to syndicators and other providers
of content for example the card industry
is interesting and this is I'm just
going to rest on this for a second this
actually turns out to be an interesting
compet for Google and Microsoft and
Yahoo and Amazon and lots of companies
these days because one of the things is
actually going on an ebay and so forth
one of the things that's going on in the
card business today is there is a
significant
disruption and there's a real drive to
end the merchant the merchant hostile
systems and replace them with a merchant
friendly system merchants for various
reasons are very upset now about the
charges they have to pay and there's a
there's a drive in the business no to
basically replace the business model
alright what does all of this have to do
with software platforms well if you
think about all the businesses that I
talked about now I can give you a lots
of lots of additional examples they're
all businesses in which essentially
there are two or more distinct consumer
groups who at least could be sources of
revenue and the business model for the
industries that I've just gone through
our situations where there are two or
more distinct groups of consumers who
need each other in some way to go back
to the example of a Vogue and your
question on readers actually liking the
advertisers makes makes this a little
bit simpler story to tell to the extent
that they that they do you have two
groups of consumers here you have
advertisers and you have subscribers and
one of the things that this magazine
does is it helps put them together and
it helps put together a particular kind
of reader and a particular kind of
advertiser and allows them to get mutual
benefits this is a platform now if you
take a look at software platforms if you
look across the full range as I'm going
to define software platforms later on in
the talk who are the customers for
software platforms well the customers
our users their developers they may be
content providers they may be hardware
makers they may in fact be advertisers
depending upon the software platform
that you're talking about and all of
those potential groups of customers in
effect that are coming to the platform
are potentially sources of revenue even
though there may be a decision that one
particular group of customer guess
things for free as is the case in
shopping malls or maybe even get things
at a significant at a significant
discount which is true for actually a
lot of car transaction
but software platforms like all the
businesses that I've just talked about
our businesses generally they don't have
to be but oftentimes their businesses
that have multiple groups of consumers
that are coming together through the
software platform and where the software
platform is creating value now there's a
new science a new economic science of
multi-sided platforms it started in
around 2000 based on the work of a
couple of friends of mine at the
University of Toulouse started in France
but has become a really hot topic and
economics and we've made tremendous
advances in this discipline over the
last over the last five years the the
basic insight from these guys and the
basic insight in the new economics of
multi-sided platforms is that there are
lots of businesses some of them knew but
actually some of them very old that are
really based on essentially the same
business model and more importantly that
business model as you try to understand
the economics of it the economics of
that business model is actually very
different from the economics that we
have we have been taught really through
a good portion of the of the 20th
century there are actually some deep
economic insights in this literature
that really turned out to be news to
economists and we've gotten them really
as a result of recognizing this pattern
that there are a lot of industries that
follow this this basic economic this
basic economic model as I said this has
become one of the hottest theories and
economics there are conferences all the
time on this lots of students are
writing doctoral dissertations on it if
you're an assistant professor or a young
person in the profession especially if
you're a theorist this is something that
people are really excited about
importantly for for you and for
businesses this is also very quickly
translating into a very new way of
thinking in terms of business strategies
and so forth and there are lots of
management insights that are coming from
this literature as well now
this literature goes well beyond the the
tried and true literature on network
effects you've all heard about network
effects positive feedback loops virtual
server chewable circles virtuous circle
virtuous circles and so forth now it
turns out that the economic literature
that drove a lot of those insights into
network effects while it contributed
quite a bit to our understanding of
network industry's missed a bunch of
fundamental points and the most
fundamental point that it missed that
turns out to be very very important in
this new science of multi-sided
platforms is the importance of balance
if you look at vogue if you look at
credit cards if you look at software
platforms if you look at singles clubs
if you look at exchanges and so forth it
turns out that getting the customer is
on board the platform in the right
proportion and getting the right
customers on board the platform in the
right proportion turns out to be
critical in fact it turns out to be more
critical than the try to intrude wisdom
that if you build chair the market will
come to you and the basic defect in the
network economics literature and the
advice that calm entrepreneurs and lots
of people got in the in the late 1990s
was this notion this mechanical notion
that if you simply build chair and get
these network effects that somehow you
have a business model what this new
literature emphasizes is that while
share is important while scale effects
are important what's really really
important is making sure that you have
the bow saw both sides on board and that
you have a business model that maintains
those two sides and is capable of in
effect igniting a reaction between the
multiple customer groups that are coming
together on the platform now the new
science of multi cited platforms is very
relevant to anyone in the software
platform business writ large and when I
say plot software platforms I'm not just
talking about Windows I'm talking about
Google's advertising search platform and
lots of other things in the information
technology world today it turns out that
the new literature multi-sided platforms
is very helpful for understanding those
kind of businesses in part because it
has some interesting new theory but also
because by recognizing that lots of
businesses share these characteristics
we've been able to pull together
empirical information from a number of
different from a number of different
industries to get a better understanding
of how things how things work so what I
would like to do next is to summarize
the new science some of the results of
the new science of multi-sided on
platforms now the secret of all these
businesses is burying out some way to
create value by bringing two or more set
to customers together that's the basic
insight for all these businesses when
you look at diners club the Apple this
fell on Frank McNamara's head was the
notion that by bringing merchants and
card holders together in a single
platform that was a way to create value
now if you take a look at the set of
businesses that I talked about in the
set of businesses that engage in
bringing multiple groups of customers
together they do three different things
they act as matchmakers so think about
speed dating they build audiences so
think about People magazine or think
about Google and they provide shared
facilities that reduce costs and provide
the elimination of duplication think
windows or think shopping malls now if
you think deeply about all the
businesses that I've just mentioned and
all of your businesses I think what
you'll see quickly is that while you can
think of matchmaking businesses and
exchange businesses and audience
building businesses and reducing costs
kind of businesses all these businesses
do each of those things to some to some
extent so if you think about vogue
what's vogue doing well we think of this
is building audiences advertising
supported media but the other thing is
doing is it's a matchmaker it's bringing
particular kinds of advertisers and
particular kinds of consumers together
it does that by product differentiation
so I I don't remove and there are
certain kind of women who do read vogue
and some who don't the ones who read it
are the ones who like the advertisements
and the end the articles if you think
about Windows okays the other thing it
does in a distant the matchmaking is in
some sense it also reduces the cost to
the advertisers we tend to trivialize
this because there's so many ways of
doing this now it is but rather than
having a billboard these advertisers can
all join in effect this single platform
and put their ads between these pages
and there's an efficiency that's created
there much in the same way the Google
creates efficiencies through if
advertising platform now if you think
about windows in the multi-sided
literature that I'm talking about we
think of windows as fundamentally
something that reduces the cost to
application developers by having in
effect shared facilities that
application developers can can use and
that provides benefits to the to the
developers but also benefits obviously
to the to the end users as well but I
mean to some extent you can think of
windows as also building up an audience
for developers by accumulating users
you're in effect selling an audience to
developers and vice versa and this is
less obvious in the case of windows
because Windows is such a standard
nowadays but if you think it's something
like Apple which through product
differentiation
is able to match different kinds of
developers with different kinds of
consumers and think about publishing
software for example now it may seem a
degree of inevitability in my discussion
of multiply cited platforms and one of
the things that I should emphasize at
the at the outside is that some
businesses really have to be multi-sided
platforms if you're interested in
getting into the dating Club or we're
matchmaking men and women business
you've got to have men and women you
have to have two sets of customers and
fundamentally that is a two sided
business there's no way around it if you
look at a lot of other businesses though
the decision to operate a multi-sided
platform is really a question of
strategy and probably the best way to
see that is to take a look at magazines
as I said 19th century magazines were
not in fact advertising-supported there
was a decision at some point the switch
from being I pay for content I put the
content together and I sell typical
single sided traditional supply chain
kind of model but then there was a a
switch over to being a two sided or
multi-sided model if you take a look at
credit cards again to take that as an
example project 1950 this was a single
sided traditional traditional product
the merchant as part of its overall
services provides a card to its
customers end of story you don't have
this two-sided platform aspect to it if
you take a look at ipod that we'll get
to later versus microsoft's presume
strategy that's another example and
we'll talk about that a little bit later
of a single-sided in effect versus a
multi-sided strategy and now we're kind
of back to a single sign of strategy so
let me quickly summarize some of the key
findings of the multi-sided literature
number one balance is absolutely
critical if you take a look at payment
cards the way diners club was able to
start frame
mcnamara was able to get about 13
restaurants signed on in Manhattan to
begin with along with 300 consumers so
he had enough consumers enough card
holders and enough restaurants to ignite
the system think about the alternative
where he had one or two restaurants at a
thousand consumers or 10,000 consumers
he may have had that at the beginning
but that's all he had that would have
been a difficult thing to ignite so you
got to have balance think about auctions
in the same way if you don't have enough
buyers and sellers it's very difficult
to have a sensible auction site if you
only have a couple of buyers and a lot
of sellers that's obviously not going to
work so balance is critical for these
platforms and it's often the key problem
that needs to be solved at the beginning
getting both the chicken and eggs on
board and in the right proportion so how
to do that well there are several things
that turn out to be very critical for
this pricing is key to getting the
balance right now many of the examples
that I've gone through are situations
where one side gets the product for free
or if you think about it more deeply
gets the product at a price that's less
than marginal cost so if you think about
newspapers we all pay for newspapers but
if you think about the economics event
business most of us get newspapers at a
price that is less than the incremental
cost of producing and distributing the
newspaper shopping malls is an example
of a situation where the price to
shoppers is zero if you look at the
windows model for developed for
developers while developers pay for
something some of the tools for windows
and so forth I don't think you think of
the the tool development side of the
business as a as a profit Center and
there's an awful lot of stuff that
developers really do get literally for
free in the case of in the case of
windows so pricing is key for a lot of
these lot of these businesses and if you
think about the diner's club model that
we
we I started I started with a couple of
minutes ago the notion of charging
merchants and letting the cartwhole is
in for free that seems like a brilliant
and obvious model in retrospect but
obviously it was a brilliant insight at
the time and for a lot of these
businesses gaining the pricing right in
knowing which side the charge in which
side not to charge turns out to be the
critical thing to get at at the start of
these businesses I'm working with a lot
of new firms in in a variety of spaces
at this point and I can tell you that
there the basic thing that they're
trying to figure out in all cases this
is especially true for anyone who's
doing mobile contents and so forth
getting the prices right getting the
balance right and getting the sides on
board and getting economics of those two
sides or three sides or four sides turns
out to be critical there's a new term in
this literature that's actually probably
very familiar to you but we've adopted
it in the economics of multi-sided
platform and that's the term
multi-homing so multi-homing for us is
the is the multi-sided economics version
of polygamy so multi-homing simply means
that the the customers of the platform
are using more than one platform so most
of us for example a getting news from
multiple sources if you look in your
wallets you almost certainly have a
credit card a debit card maybe a charge
card maybe multiple of those so Europe
multihoming on cards using multiple card
platforms if you go to a merchant you'll
notice that that there are a lot of
stickers on the door so the merchant is
also accepting a lot of cards so the
merchant is multi-homing as well if you
take a look at Windows Windows is an
example of a product where virtually all
consumers except for a handful of geeks
real extreme geeks are basically single
homing they're just using windows
they're not using windows and the mac OS
even if they have the new mac OS that
runs windows very few people are doing
that very few people simultaneously
running Windows and Linux so that's an
example in effect of single homing but
if you look at developers
a lot of developers multi-home in the
sense that they melt they develop for
multiple platforms and it's certainly
true for example in in video games one
of the implications of multi-homing is
that if you're an owner of a platform
business you don't like multi-homing you
really would like people to be
monogamous and you like them to be
monogamous on both sides and therefore
platform businesses been a lot of effort
trying to persuade people to be
monogamous so ebay for example has been
successful or pretty successful with his
feedback forum encouraging both
merchants and consumers to be a little
bit dedicated to that platform and
reward miles for credit cards do sort of
the sort of the same thing although not
nearly as effectively the other key
strategy that the multi-sided economics
literature emphasizes and again for
those of you who study lots of different
businesses this will seem obvious it's
called the more key strategy but lots of
you may call it the anchor tenant
strategy in order to get the two sides
on board the platform one of the things
that is a common strategy and lots of
these businesses is to get a significant
a prestige customer on one side because
by doing that you'll attract customers
on the other side so Frank McNamara with
the credit card he gets a number of the
elite restaurants and then had an
onboard his platform that's good for
attracting card holders if you go to a
shopping mall there's a North drums or a
Macy's or saxe or whatever and that
tends to anchor them all and attracts
other other stores and there are lots of
examples lots of examples of this in the
case of video games obviously if you
want to start a new video game platform
one of the things you want to do is you
want to get a really really great game
to sort of anchor that platform in order
to get customers on the on the other
side now multi-sided platforms as I've
defined them have been around for
millennia almost since the beginning of
time but to go back to some of the old
famous multi-sided platforms so the Rome
forum is an example of a multi-sided
platform
if you go to China in in China marriage
brokers or sort of like investment
bankers they're called mirin and
basically they they they acted like
investment bankers and they had term
sheets and they brought men and women
together and there are lots of those
kind of businesses that have been around
again for millennia if you go back to
the start of money the modern modern
money coins was basically invented in
Lydia in about 700 BC that was a state
basically entering the platform business
by creating a payment instrument a
standardized coin that both buyers and
sellers would be willing to use so these
kind of platforms go back for a very
long number of years however what's
really exciting about this area now is
that this branch of economics and
business strategy helps elucidate lots
of businesses that are starting up at
the beginning of the 21st century and
the reason this is happening the reason
we're seeing a lot more platform
businesses nowadays is because as you
all know reduce communication costs
reduce the other processing costs it's
much easier to operate these platforms
on a virtual basis and the whole idea of
putting together communities and so
forth is much easier now than it ever
run than it ever was so I haven't really
talked about the the book yet and
somewhere around I have a well somewhere
around as a copy of the book let me see
if I have a copy of the book oh we have
lots of copies of the book okay so I'm
actually going to get to another book at
the end of my at the end of my talk but
this is invisible engines and what
invisible engines does is it really uses
the framework of multi-sided platform
economics to glean insights in a bunch
of different industries so we use the
lens of multi-sided economics to study
the obvious ones the history of personal
computers and the birth of of the of the
Windows platform and the
and the mac platform and so forth but we
also study video games we study PDAs we
study digital media and we study lots of
examples of mobile phones we study
tailing and we study
advertising-supported search engines
although not as deeply as we do some of
these some of the other industries and
basically the idea behind the book is to
use the lens of multi-sided economics to
get an understanding by looking across
these diverse industries of the
strategies that have worked and the
strategies that haven't worked so that's
what the that's what the book is about
so let me let me not taste so much that
you don't pick up copies of the of the
book so let me just let me just
highlight a few things that we that we
do in the book and then I want to
quickly at the end talk about another
book that I have coming out in in a few
months which is more of a management
more of a management book so one of the
interesting things if you look across
the diversity of software platform
businesses and platform businesses more
generally is there's a very fundamental
decision to be made early on and over
the course of the development of the
business and industry which is how you
architect how do you design the
ecosystem that you want to that you want
to be as I mentioned before for many of
these businesses being multi cited is
really a strategic choice in the case of
in the case of digital media players
Apple for all intents and purposes when
single sided and we can talk if you have
any questions about why I view the Apple
and iPod iTunes as essentially a
single-sided a single sided model
whereas Microsoft up until recently when
when multi-sided Apple made the decision
to basically control all aspects of its
of its supply chain and in effect sold a
single experience to the consumer
Microsoft on the other hand took the
traditional strategy which was common
for Microsoft but also comment from any
other software platform of producing a
software platform
form and then trying to build an
ecosystem with hardware manufacturers
and content providers and so forth and
customers obviously all all coming
together on that on that platform now
there are advantages and the
disadvantages of those of those two
approaches the opp the advantage
obviously of the single silent approach
is that you get to control all aspects
of the consumer experience you get to
have very tight integration of all the
components and that has certain that has
certain advantages and in particular it
has very significant advantages when
you're trying to ignite a market and
trying to attract consumers on one side
in order to get things going and I'll
give an example of that in just a second
the advantage of the multi-sided
approach as Microsoft has learned with
windows and a number of other of its
successful platforms is that the
multi-sided approach tends the really
fuel scale effects it tends to really
ignite these positive feedback effects
because you have all these customers
coming on one side and I'm thinking
about developers as if that customer is
helping to fuel users on the other side
and then and then back and forth that's
certainly the case with the example of a
diners club by having this multi-sided
model diners club and the payment card
industry generally has been able to get
both cart holes and merchants basically
feeding on each other and growing the
system explosively so their advantage in
the disadvantages of both one of the
things that we say yeah coming
differentiate between platform and a
marketplace in
single-sided and multi-sided because
like yep like an iPod of course you're
having people be able to buy music from
you know from music suppliers and that's
clearly a marketplace yeah it's not
really a platform in the sense that it's
a closed model of greed but it is
analogous to like the shopping mall
shoppers store up there so is that
shopping mall a platform in your mind
marketplace or is it is is like that
shopping mall is that is that a
multi-sided by wish shopping while
you're talking about well the industry
you've got right there yep you got
multiple industries there yep yep the
shopping with the shopping mall is a
platform so yep and it's a multi-sided
platform so let
no but it's a it's a different if it's
really a different business model so if
you think about the shopping mall model
be the developer builds them all and you
have an empty space and at that point in
order to have a business it needs two
sets of customers and it can derive
revenue from either or both set the
customers in that situation and in the
case of the shopping malls what it does
is it rent space to the to the merchants
and the merchants don't have to stay
there forever they stay there at the at
the decision of the shopping mall the
shopping mall decide what stories can be
there it makes all those decisions to
define the experience of the shopping
mall but it makes it makes money by
renting space to the stores and by
taking a cut oftentimes of the of the
sales and it does a variety of things in
order to attract the shoppers if they
can charge an upfront fee for the device
they can charge your subscription fee
they can charge you a purse on fee and
they can also charge you know access to
the suppliers of the music yeah so in
this area the ipod itunes example is
actually a little bit of this in
supermarkets where there's also a
question of the extent to which it it
gets into the two-sided aspect of this
there's actually some debate within
people who are in this literature on how
exactly to think about the ipod itunes
example the way I think about the ipod
itunes example and the best way to see
this is to contrast it with what
microsoft is done if you think about the
ipod itunes example for all intents and
purposes it's a limit it's a supply
chain in the following sense although
you know you can you can debate aspects
of this Apple is interested in basically
selling stuff to end consumers and for
it's standpoint the content providers
are people that it is going to to
basically same by music is a little bit
inaccurate but for all intents and
purposes you have the content providers
that are basically selling stuff to
Apple just like you would sell stuff to
a simple market Apple then puts that on
the itunes store and then that's made
available to the to the to the Apple to
the Apple consumers Apple is not
spending the kind of effort that you
would think about with with many
platforms in evangelizing itself for the
content provider side there's an
economic transaction there it's
essentially engaging in economic
transaction with the content providers
and I don't want to make that too
extreme okay tournament the zune yep no
no I'm not talking about the zoo I'm
talking I'm talking about presume so the
Microsoft strategy presume is you you
generate it you create a software
platform and the way you monetize that
software platform well the way you hope
the way you hope to or hope to monetize
that software platform is just as with
Windows your customers are in effect the
suppliers of the of the hardware it's
the consumers obviously and it's also
content providers and web portals
basically anyone that's willing to set
up a business to provide content to the
users of that of that software platform
and you can think of each one of those
groups as in effect a set of customers
for you clearly in that case the
platform failed relative to
ipod right yes it has not yet succeeded
okay okay yeah so that that's the
distinction and and there there are
complexities here and you know there are
a number of businesses that are I
characterize them as one-sided going on
to an example of a one-sided one-sided
business going on to is walmart for
example where to a lot of you know in a
lot of ways it's it's it's buy stuff
sell to consumers but Walmart is getting
to the point where it's it didn't affect
a platform which shelf space that it is
making available to to businesses and
that's an example of a one-sided going
on going on too okay the the next thing
I just wanted to touch touch briefly
because on i think i'm running out of
how much time do I just a few minutes
yeah I want to take some questions i
think what i'm going to do is I want to
talk briefly of just about some pricing
principles and I'm going to go to the
I'm going to go to the blackboard to do
this so um the interesting thing about
these kind of platform businesses is
when you think about how to monetize the
platform there are a few dimensions you
can play with and there are other
businesses where this may also be true
but it's particularly interesting in the
case of platforms so in the case of
platforms you think you can think about
two kinds of fees to charge people you
can think about economists would say
fixed fees and variable fees but you can
think of access fees and usage views so
think about a charge for access and you
can think about a charge for usage and
you have both sets of fees that you can
charge to two group one and the group
too and if you take a look at software
platforms generally but also multi-sided
platforms generally you see a lot of
variation and how people have solved the
monetizing the platform
by making different choices on the
extent to which they have excess fees
and usage fees for custom group one or
customer group two and I'm just doing
the two-sided example here they're
obviously can be more and the extent to
which these are positive or negative the
extent to which they making profits on
this so let me give you an example of
let me give you an example of credit
cards so we have card holders and we
have merchants and think about the
economics of that business putting the
financing aspect of credit cards off to
one side so in the case of card holders
many cards have a fixed fee which is
positive but lots of cards don't have an
explicit usage charge no one has ever
been charged a per-transaction fee for
using a card but lots of cards have
rewards or some other inducement to
actually use the card for transactions
so cards are this is only true for some
cards so I would characterize it as a
usage fee that is zero or negative
people are paid to use the car think
about it from the standpoint of
merchants on the other hand merchants by
and large don't have to pay anything in
order to accept cards aside from getting
the getting the terminal equipment and
maybe some initial sign up charge so
they're essentially zero but on the
other hand they do pay a transaction fee
so a typical merchant will pay some of
the neighborhood of two to
two-and-a-half to three percent in order
to use cards so this is the business
model that has basically been used in
the in the card industry and as I
mentioned before the net effect of these
is putting the credit card financing
feature of cards aside this doesn't
generate profits this does let me give
you let me give you another example
which is advertising supported media so
let's do
which is close to your hearts I know so
take the advertiser and take the take
the reader and think about how that
platform is typically monetized in the
case of newspapers and magazines the
advertisers typically don't have any set
up charge any entry fee to getting on
the platform so that's typically zero
and while you may think of there being
an impression you may think of vogue is
having a fee of $100,000 a two hundred
thousand dollars for an ad if you look
at the business overall it's basically
an impressions based business so
television and newspapers and magazines
and so forth if the it's really a usage
fee in the sense that it's the number of
eyeballs that are expected to to see the
ad that is the source of the of the fee
even though it may be a lump something
in the case of the reader it's
interesting there's a small positive fee
for access the subscription fee for the
for the magazine which again is
typically subsidized on the other hand
there's no fee at all for usage we
cannot get off paid according to the
number of times you look at the magazine
and and so forth and then let me just
quickly go to software platforms and
give you my take on on this so in this
case we'll have I'm sorry nicely
distributors developer software
developers so we have is vs and we have
we have users think about the fees that
most software platforms charge
there's essentially no usage fee no
one's charged typically for the extent
to which they're using api's although if
you start taking a look at at them at
the Google as a software platform we can
have a discussion over that but for most
software platforms there's no usage fee
for the API set to the to the users to
the extent that there's an access fee I
would argue that the access fee for is
BS is probably subsidized but you could
argue that at zero or you could argue
that you're charging them a little bit
of money but I would say that it's
probably probably negative and then if
you look at the at the user side users
are charged a fee basically for access
to the platform you charge the fee to
even the OEM is charged a fee or the
end-user assures it be if it's the three
people who buy a retail there's an
access fee for the software platform but
then at least at the moment with the the
model that that you and most people have
at the moment there's really no usage
fee so that's the economic model for pro
software platforms and the only point I
really wanted to get with this is that
that how you check off these boxes is
very important for monetizing the
platform and it is a matter of
discretion and one of the interesting
things that we highlight in the book is
the distinction between the business
model for traditional software platforms
like Windows and symbian and and so
forth and another important software
platform which is the software platforms
for video game consoles so if you look
at the software platform for video game
consoles and and I'm going to move on
from here if you look at the if you look
at the business model for video game
consoles the buyer of the of the
software platform on the video game
console is basically being subsidized
you get the console for generally
something that that manufacturing cost
or even maybe a little bit less you're
not charged for how often you use the
platform if on the other hand you're a
game developer unlike the windows Apple
symbian model of traditional software
platforms
the money is actually made on the
developer side of the business and it's
made by in effect a a usage fee since
it's a you can think of it as a usage
fee since it's in effect a percent of
the of the game revenue that the game
developer is getting from the from the
users so the only point here is there
are very interesting differences in
terms of the how things and monetize and
lots of degrees of freedom for these
multi-sided models that turn out to be
turn out to be quite interesting so let
me actually show you one cartoon I was
going to talk to you about about
bundling this just demonstrates that we
have cartoons in the in the book one of
my one of my favorites here and then
just a quick advertisement for my next
book which is actually a general book on
two-sided platforms multi-sided
platforms that covers really everything
is written for a managerial audience
this is the framework that we develop in
that book and the kind of insights that
we provide to businesses that are
starting platforms in a lot of different
areas and then that's actually the book
which is coming out in in there I feel a
little bit bad that I'm then i'm free
riding on an MIT press sponsored event
with a book at the end published by
harvard business school press but
hopefully won't get back to them and of
course Harvard Business School would be
happy to do the reverse so the book
that's coming out in May is catalyst
code by me and ditch fallen Z which is
an application of the general framework
of multi-sided economics to very diverse
businesses everything from eight minute
dating to hospitals to shopping malls to
one of my favorites which is roppongi
hills in the middle of Tokyo which is an
example of a big shopping mall kind of a
city within a city and we go through
some of the insights insights there so
let me stop there and take and take any
questions that people help
yeah can you give some examples of
platforms that have like three or four
or a larger number of sides yeah so um
so zoo so an example of a platform that
has multiple sides would be on any
platform to give you an example that um
um so let's take windows let's take
windows media player as as an example so
windows media player and your your your
windows media platform think of that as
a software platform okay that platform
has content providers it has device
manufacturers and it has end-users so
that's an example of that's an example
and I'm sorry it has it has it actually
has another side which our application
developers so you have content providers
that are using the windows media
platform in order to encode and
distribute content you have application
developers who are using it to develop
applications using the API set you have
end-users and to some extent you have
hardware manufacturers they may be using
it and some of the api's and protocols
that are that are that are exposed in
order to do in order to do hardware
devices if you take a look at Yahoo so
yahoo has it has content provision it
has advertisers anna has users so that's
a that's a three-sided platform now if
you look across platforms generally i'd
say that the predominance of them are
are in fact two-sided now one of the
interesting things that i wasn't able to
cover is the really scary thing for any
kind of a platform business is what i
call
colliding or intersecting catalysts and
that's the situation where you're a
platform which slides a and B and
there's a new platform that's created
which has sides a B and C or has sides B
and C but where the sources of revenue
are different so you can think of this
as Google work to get into into
web-based software versus Microsoft were
Microsoft not to get into advertising
based software Google and effect has a
different source of revenue that under
your current model you don't have so
that's an example of an intersecting
catalyst where the fact that the cattle
that the that the two-sided platforms
the three-sided platforms have different
sources of revenue turns out to be quite
important for survival in the in the
ecosystem
or else it will await move
in addition to you mentioned the anchor
score yep concept as one way to
jumpstart the platform adoption what is
some of the other common ways of prior
to that the common waves of
jump-starting a platform well the common
way of jump-starting a platform is by is
in fact by subsidizing one side to get
on to get on board sometime that subsidy
turns out to be permanent in other cases
it turns out to be temporary so we go
back to the card example it's very
common for card entrance to subsidize
consumers early on and I was in fact the
case for diners club for about the for
about the first year and then that that
changed but but typically the way the
thing gets ignited is by figuring out
which side you need the most in order to
get the other side and in most cases is
going to be an answer to that question
which side needs the other side most and
once you figure out which side needs the
other side most you can subsidize that
side or give that side a really good
deal in order to deliver delivery to the
other side and then the other example of
jump-starting one of these multi-sided
businesses is engaging in what I would
call the one the the 12 punch strategy
an example of that an extreme example of
that is what Tom did in order to enter
the PDA business and what Microsoft has
had has done in order to enter the video
game console business so if you take a
look at pom pom in its introduction was
completely single sided it I mean it
didn't produce its own operating system
it didn't produce its own hardware but
basically it was in charge it's
subcontracted the hardware it got an
operating system from somewhere and
integrated a ten hand writing software
in to the PDA and it got and it got a
bunk and it wrote a bunch of
applications or bought a bunch of
applications and created that as a as an
integrated bundle so it
appeared as a single side of platform
just like ipod did but the plan the plan
was to do that in order to attract users
so they attracted a lot of users and
then the idea was one that once they get
up to a million users or so which they
got they got very quickly then they
turned on their evangelization machine
they had api's exposed and started going
to developers to try to get developers
to do application so within 18 months
they had their first developer
conference and so forth so that was an
example of igniting the platform by in
effect controlling one side of the
platform tightly until you've got the
other side on board now in the case of
xbox when xbox started in an ideal world
you guys wouldn't have developed any
games on your own you just would have
relied on the extensive group of game
developers around the world to do that
for you but no one was certain that
Microsoft Xbox would be successful so to
ignite xbox one of the things that
Microsoft did and again this is a not
uncommon strategy among among these kind
of platform businesses you self supplied
you went out and develop some of your
own games and bought a bunch of game
companies in order to deploy their games
on on the Xbox um and to an extent sony
Sony did the same thing at its start but
that's not the permanent business model
the long run business model is to move
the game development off unless you
happen to discover that you're
particularly good at that side of the
business which you could argue in the
case of windows happen to be the case
with with with office applications but
but generally the plan is to move that
off to other people and then to focus on
the software platform so self supply
often turns out to be an interesting way
to ignite these platforms and then the
final example which is really very much
like the anchor tenant strategy is to
engage in an exclusive relationship so
if you look at at Real Player if you
look at Google at the moment for example
we
syndication deals those are situations
in which the platform is engaging in
exclusive contracts in order to build up
one side of them on the market just as
long as she says you could ask my more
you can ask one more have you looked at
the
effect of these new Internet platforms
which essentially reduce friction
whether it's search whether it's access
whether it's transactional producer
internet backbone Internet platforms
always in a platter yeah what would that
what is that reduction and friction and
you know kind of the marketplace effect
bringing these different types of
consumers of customers together in a way
that reduces the overall cost of the
left that interaction have you looked at
what impact that has on the economics of
these businesses in terms of pricing in
terms of I haven't looked at in terms of
pricing I guess I make a cup I make a
couple of oxidation one of the results
of that new technology is it does lead
to a dramatic reduction in the cost of
setting up one of these platforms and a
tremendous expansion in the amount of
economic value that can be generated for
different communities around the globe
if you think about these platform
businesses they're really very
interesting because they're there
they're all in a sense like like typical
exchange in the sense that when you and
I come together and exchange something
and it becomes easier for us to do that
we both become better off because we
move a good from its lower values into a
higher value use and what these
platforms do is they in effect bring
different parties together and provide
the opportunity to generate that value
and the reason we're seeing so many of
these businesses coming into being isn't
just because they're they're cheaper to
create now but because there are so many
more opportunities now to generate
enormous sums of value by getting people
together in the example that I that I
given the book is is ebay if you think
about the and this is a calculation that
economists haven't done but if you think
about the value that eBay has generated
as a result of providing an efficient
platform for small valued
distant transactions that take place its
enormous and the reason it's enormous is
because you're not just improving the
efficiency of an existing transaction by
reducing transaction costs you're
permitting transactions that otherwise
wouldn't have taken place so the full
sum of the surplus that being generated
by by by those transactions is being
created by that kind of a platform and
there are lots of other examples just
like that if you look at advertising
supported search or a lot of these
things basically there are transactions
and things that are coming into being
that previously didn't even exist and
you're there for by bringing people
together you're creating value almost
out of thin air and it's really just a
kind of a remarkable aspect of these
businesses in how they do it it's not
just making things more efficient it's
really bringing things together and
releasing these incredible values that
can be had by just bringing different
parties together in one place okay thank
you